We're providing you with an asset drop,
view the link below,
so that you can download the images
and include them in the app.
When we open up the assets ZIP file,
we see that the same icon
is provided at different sizes
for different resolutions.
In the drawable MDPI folder,
we see the assets that will be used
on an MDPI device.
In the drawable HDPI folder,
we see the assets
that will be used on an HDPI device.
And the same goes for the other folders.
Under the res directory copy over
all the asset folders
provided in the download.
Clicking on an image shows a preview of it
and the size and pixels is also shown.
At this time you can also remove
the old placeholder ic launcher icons.
Our new launcher icons
are located in mipmap folders.
These are distinct folders
from the drawable folders.
If you build an APK
for a target screen resolution like HDPI,
the Android asset packaging tool, AAPT,
can strip out the drawables
for other resolutions you don't need.
But if it's in the mipmap folders,
then these assets will stay in the APK
regardless of the target resolution.
But when would you need
an image at a resolution
different than the resolution
of the device?
Well, one example
is the Android launcher app,
which controls the home screen
as well as the All App store.
The launcher app won't use the icon
at the current density of the device,
but rather pulls an icon
for the next highest resolution up.
For an XXHDPI device like the Nexus 5,
normally the assets will be pulled
from the drawable XXHDPI folder.
However, in this case the launcher icon
will pull the XXXHDPI version
of the launcher icon.
That will make the larger app icons
appear sharper on the all apps screen.
In the code replace @drawable/iclauncher
with @mipmap/iclauncher
because of the new location of the icons.
For the rest of the icons
modify the forecast list
and the details screen to display
the right weather icon
instead of the placeholder one.
See the hints below
in the instructor notes.
Using the helper functions
we've provided in the gist below,
you can map the weather condition code
to the icon that you'll need.
This is what the app should look like
when you're done with this step.
Note that there are two types
of each weather icon,
a gray icon and a colored art image.
In the main forecast list
we'll be using the gray icon.
However, for the today layout,
we'll use the colored icon.
When you go inside the detail activity,
you'll also use the colored icon.
At this time, you can also remove
any images you hard coded
into the layout XML, because
they'll be populated dynamically now.